Do you think that our democracy
current western either uh.
Enough to,
uh,
to accelerate the ecological transition?
Are we armed for it.
Ha, ha.
So I think,
we come back to,
to this sentence on
green democracy and democratize ecology.
There are many things.
First, our
institutions have not been thought of.
Uh.
Could integrate uh.
The question of non-human beings,
of nature, uh.
Of the animal et cetera.
So, uh,
that is,
we talk about it a lot
in the episode with Florent Coureau on the
ecological accounting.
Yeah, yeah,
but ecological accounting,
but also the constitution which is not ecological,
so she was uh.
Enriched, uh.
Uh, time,
uh.
Finally,
Jacques Chirac with Nathalie coscius,
comorized.
We enrich the constitution to reintroduce uh.
About ecology,
but it's next to the constitution.
And would say,
in the practice and history of our
institutions,
this question of nature is absent.